تعتمد اوكرانيا على مجموعه من انظمه
الدفاع الجوي تختلف كل منها في مدى
الاشتباك واولها سوفيتي الصنع وسنعتمد
كييف مثالا لتوضيح مدى المنظومات نظام 300
يصل مداه الى 250 كيلومترا تم تطويره ابان
فتره الاتحاد السوفيتي وهو قادر على
التصدي للصواريخ البالستيه التي لا تتجاوز
سرعتها
4500 متر في الثانيه
تتضمن المنظومه الاحدث رادارا بعيد المدى
لاكتشاف الاهداف المعاديه وعربت قياده
لتحليل البيانات وسته عربات تعمل كمنصات
اطلاق للصواريخ اضافه لرادار قصير المدى
لتتبع الاهداف وتوجيه الصواريخ حصلت
اوكرانيا مع استمرار الحرب على اسلحه
غربيه لتعويض التكنولوجيا الروسيه ومنها
منظومه بيترييت الامريكيه التي يرسل مداها
الى 160 كيلومترا تعتبر نظام دفاع بعيد
المدى قادرا على حمايه المنشات العسكريه
والقواعد من الهجمات الجويه
يشمل هذا النظام رادارا ومحطه تحكم ومولد
طاقه ومنصه اطلاق ومركبات دعم منظومه
نيسونز الامريكيه بمدى يصل الى خمسين
كيلومترا وهو نظام متوسط المدى يمكنه
التعامل مع مقاتلات ومروحيات وصواريخ كروز
ومسيرات تشمل المنظومه رادارات ومجسات
وقاذفات صواريخ يمكنها اعتراض الاهداف
خارج نطاق الرؤيه والاشتباك مع عده اهداف
بشكل متزامن
منظومه ايرستيل المانيه بمدى يصل لنحو 40
كيلومترا من افضل انظمه الدفاع متوسطه
المدى تستطيع سد الطائرات المقاتله
والمروحيات وصواريخ كروز والمسيرات يوفر
النظام حمايه شامله داخل دائره مدى
الصاروخ الدفاعي ضد الاهداف المتحركه
ودرعا واقيا حول المدن والمنشاه
[موسيقى]